this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula
the ad-free creator controlled streaming
service when you sign up for curiosity
stream at the link below
[Music]
we want every american to know the
dignity of a hard day's work
we can lift our citizens from welfare to
work
from dependence to independence
this is hard work you where they really
do work really hard
uh they love our country they love faith
uh they love values and they love
working hard
it's indicative of a problem in our
culture where we've started to sideline
this notion of personal responsibility
and
personal responsibility as a as a
foundation of our culture
it's important because it leads to
empowerment
it gives us the agency to control our
own destiny
if a young person believes that the
climate the global warming
problem on the climate is something that
needs to be tackled quickly
and they can't wait until they grow up
and become prime ministers to do it
do you think collective responsibility
overrides individual responsibility
in a huge issue like that no
have you ever been told to pull yourself
up by your bootstraps ever heard someone
chastise the poor for making bad
decisions or praise the rich for making
good ones
how many times have you heard someone
assert that the us is the best country
on earth because of our individual
freedom
these are all part of the same
phenomenon and while present in some
cultures outside the us
the mindset is particularly intense here
in this episode we're going to take a
brief look at individualism and consider
why it's a deeply flawed worldview
individualism is in the air we breathe
we watch movies about individual heroes
saving the day
we are taught that history is made by
individual great men and we read think
pieces about how individuals in poverty
make good or bad choices
because this ideology is so universally
accepted
it has earned the label of common sense
even suggesting that individuals may not
be primarily
much less entirely responsible for their
circumstances is cause for mockery and
dismissal
to blame structures or systems or
society is seen as childish weakness
as an attempt to shield yourself or
others from accountability
the trouble is that individualism is an
utterly absurd way of explaining the
world
in 2018 a group of harvard researchers
analyzed data from the u.s census
and attempted to find correlations
between a person's life story and their
current income
they discovered that there was such a
strong connection between the place
someone is born and their future income
that they put together a map called the
opportunity atlas
which shows the median incomes of people
born in each zip code
and even predicts what those incomes
will be in the future in 2015
another study found a similar link
between your future income and your
parents wealth
the report stated the wage gap for
people from different backgrounds is
significant
the expected income of people raised in
well-off families in the 90th percentile
that is the top 90 of the national
median household income
is about 200 larger than the expected
income of children raised in poor
families
in the 10th percentile and about 75
percent larger than that of children
raised in middle class families
in the 50th percentile what's more
people raised in middle class families
will earn close to double what children
from lower income families earn in
adulthood
put simply by combining these studies
sociologists are able to predict your
lifetime income
based on the zip code you were born in
and how much money your parents make
not based on how hard working you are
not based on your personal qualities or
capitalist instincts
know the circumstances of your birth are
the single largest predictors of your
financial success
if everyone truly were entirely or even
mostly in control of their destiny
if the myth of individualism were true
how could that be possible
the ridiculousness of the equal
opportunity and individual success story
becomes even clearer when we look at the
supposedly self-made people that
individualists point to as proof
elon musk supposedly an iron man style
brain genius
enjoyed family wealth from apartheid
businesses which he has translated into
two companies which abuse government
subsidies and profit from wasteful
non-solutions to climate change
bill gates the founding father of
self-made tech moguls was one of the
first students in america to have his
own computers
and had direct connections to tech
corporations through his father
but those are just modern examples if
you'd like a truly telling example
a 2016 study found that between the
years 1427 and 2016
florence italy has been ruled by the
same families
that is a period of 600 years at least
12 generations in which the plague
the renaissance the industrial
revolution two world wars
the creation of capitalism and modern
technology itself has failed to disrupt
florence's structures of wealth and
power
if the story of individual hard work
determining success
or the inverse story of laziness causing
failure were true
surely one child in those 12 generations
of florentine elites would have been
born without the magical hard work juice
which we are told determines success
the notion of equal opportunity we are
constantly being sold on is incompatible
with any heritable family wealth
much less 600 years of it and what about
bigotry
how can we claim that anyone has enough
power over their life path to punish
them
for failure when we know for a fact that
racism
sexism and discrimination wildly change
your opportunities in life
being a woman drastically affects your
likely type of future employment
decreases your future income and
determines whether you spend years of
your life doing domestic work both paid
and unpaid
black americans are born with roughly
eight times less family wealth
are underrepresented in elections even
after votes are counted
and are far more likely to face both
hiring and workplace discrimination
compared to white americans
race and employment type are deeply
linked in 2019
the u.s bureau of labor statistics found
that hispanic americans are nearly twice
as likely to work service construction
or industrial jobs as their white peers
and therefore twice as likely to face
the health problems that kind of
employment causes
health outcomes including life
expectancy and future mental health
issues are connected to your race your
gender identity and the zip code you
were born in
black communities as one example are far
more likely to be subjected to toxic
lead paint and unclear water
both of which can cause lifelong
illnesses transgender people are much
more likely to face depression as a
result of being unable to transition or
because of the bigotry they face from
some corners of society
both groups are more likely to be
murdered outright often by the police
and far less likely to have those
murders solved conservatives and
liberals alike have been repeating for
generations that individuals
not structures are to blame for human
suffering reagan proclaimed that
government is the problem never the
solution
thatcher asserted that there is no such
thing as society
but if this is the case if the storybook
protagonist-centered tales we tell
are real how can we possibly explain the
mountains of statistically significant
links between
race poverty gender and birth location
to future health
wealth and happiness how can we explain
why some countries
namely the ones with more socialist
policies have such low rates of poverty
and homelessness
while others hop from crisis to crisis
every year
could it be coincidence sheer chance or
as argued by the likes of ben shapiro
pseudoscientific debunked bigotry the
most basic facts of modern life utterly
contradict anti-systemic individualist
thinking
to highlight that contradiction let's
try to explain these facts with
individualist logic
women and non-white people by sheer
coincidence
all individually chose to be paid less
for more demanding jobs
also by coincidence they chose to work
those jobs and be paid less than women
and non-white people in other similarly
developed countries
simultaneously people born in the same
zip codes all just happened to make
choices that led them to similar incomes
similar lifespans and similar rates of
disease those born to poor families
chose with little or no outside
influence to work lower paying jobs
the rich also chose of their own accord
and without significant systemic
advantages to work higher paying jobs
the huge differences in the inequalities
between america and other wealthy
nations
is also a coincidence caused by
americans choosing to be lazier
rather than consider that centuries of
enslavement and systemic racism has
sabotaged the quality of life for black
americans
individualists insist that black
individuals choose to live in poverty
more frequently than non-black people
rather than consider that society exists
individualists have created a web of
absurdities and chosen to live there
they also insist that none of these
absurdities are racist
sexist or classist we shouldn't temper
our language here
anyone who claims that individual
choices rather than systems entirely
determine how most people live
should be dismissed outright it's an
embarrassing and absurd worldview
and even the tiniest bit of research
should make that clear i've left some
links to further reading in the
description
like many aspects of american capitalism
individualism is a worldview created not
to explain the world but to control it
it's designed to fragment strong
communities turn workers against each
other
and diminish the power of solidarity
among the people when you see yourself
as the morally upright hero and everyone
else has competition
you're turning your back on what it
means to be human there's plenty to go
around
or at least there would be if it weren't
all funneled straight to the top
to the people who manufactured the idea
of individualism
make no mistake this worldview does not
benefit you
we all need to make an attempt at
deprogramming ourselves
of casting off decades of toxic
individualist propaganda
and rebuild the ideals of unity and
solidarity
[Music]
when engaging with history it's easy to
fall into the great man mindset
erroneously thinking that history is
driven by a handful of superhuman
individuals
but figures like martin luther king jr
while certainly important and principled
in their own right
are always carried by mass movements in
mlk's case
he supported and was supported by his
fellow black americans fighting for
equal rights
if you'd like to learn more about the
civil rights movement i highly recommend
you check out king a filmed record on
curiosity stream
it's a great two-part documentary
following mlk on his journey from
regional activist to becoming the face
of the civil rights movement
curiosity stream is an established
streaming platform with a solid track
record
of caring about great educational
content and the financial security of
those who produce it
they've got thousands of non-fiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
as you probably know youtube doesn't
treat its creators very well
that's why some of my youtuber friends
and i teamed up to build nebula
so we don't have to worry about being
demonetized as educational creators
ourselves we love curiositystream so
we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiositystream at the link
below
you'll also get access to nebula 100
free that's less than 15 bucks a year
for both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all still waiting
for the vaccine
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiosity stream
or check out nebula's original content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism you can also watch
all my videos as they were intended ad
free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week